let's go to the phone lines at six one
seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty
we will start with our caller from the
two
zero one area code and it might take
just a moment to make sure
uh that the caller can hear me
and that i can hear the caller caller
from 201 can you hear me you are on
right now
yeah hi can you hear me i can how are
you who's this
hi um i'm joshua i'm from new jersey
great what's on your mind today
yeah so my question um it's uh it's
about the pandemic that's going on
yes yeah so
um obviously the clone of our deaths
have recently surpassed 160 000
which if you do the math is more than
5911s
yes and obviously besides the death the
pandemic has cost
people's jobs and their houses and so
much more yet
despite all of that republicans and
their voters have remained
firmly ignorant of the severity of this
pandemic so with all of that in mind
my question is um just how much worse do
you think this pandemic has to get for
republicans and their voters to finally
realize the sheer
gravity of the situation and thereby
commit to substantial action
maybe even republicans like passing
actual release bills
i believe that uh it will not get
that bad enough for them
uh while donald trump is still president
if he loses in november and so what what
i mean by that is
if biden wins in november it will still
not be bad enough at that point for
republicans to say
you know our approach was not the right
one when you look at just about every
other country with some few exceptions i
just don't think it will get that bad
because it's a combination of ignorance
denial
this feeling of inevitability that like
listen this it is what it is we just we
can't stop our lives when of course as
you're pointing out a lot of those
hundred and almost 170 000 deaths now
those many of those were optional and
they came from not taking the right
measures i i don't think we're going to
get there
i think that it's going to time out now
if biden doesn't win
and trump gets another four years i
think that
he's going to be saved by the bell
anyway because before republicans say
it's now bad enough that we need to do
more we'll have a vaccine this so so i
think that they it will not get to the
point where republicans say whoa we got
it wrong we've got to do a rethink
yeah yeah oh yeah i definitely agree i
was on the
pessimistic side myself that republicans
would just commit to their ignorance
yeah and yeah i mean it's just so
frustrating because well
um ethnically i'm from south korea and i
watch
uh the korean news every night and it's
we're an absolute embarrassment yeah the
united states
like um on like the south korean uh
news outlets like they they bring up
entire segments where they basically
just
roast the united states for 30 minutes
plus
like they'll bring up clips of like the
adults having temper tantrums about
wearing masks they'll
bring up like clips of trump saying to
slow down testing
yeah we're an absolute embarrassment
it's so frustrating that
not only is the man in the white house
like
denying the significance of this problem
but everyone
around him is also committing to
ignorance yeah when i said that the u.s
is a laughingstock it was not a
metaphor it was i mean literally the
world is
in shock at how poorly we are dealing
with this and you know the problem with
with all of it is the people who
most need to hear it don't care that
south korea
and france france and the netherlands
that they're all laughing at us because
they
they're like we we do what we do we
don't care about you know [ __ ]
europeans or people in asia halfway
across
they just don't care so it's like
there's no reaching them sadly but it is
what it is and hopefully we can remove
trump sooner than later
yeah definitely yeah it's just so
frustrating
all right thanks david thank you i
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you